that
we have
to people.
[Silence]
there
Method
three
set.
What?
What could
us
by the people of paradise? What has
landed you in this damn nation that you
are in? They will respond
with four things. Four things. That is
the formula of a person gaining
admittance into the hellfire.
He says the first thing that they will
say,
"We were not of the people who made
salah. We were not of them. We were not
with them."
This could mean we were not of the
Muslim because the people of Salah
is a synonym for the Muslim. If we are
to say who are the Muslim, they are the
people of Salah. Who are the people of
Salah? They are the Muslim. So it's a
synonym.
This verse has a double meaning. It
means we were not of the Muslim and we
did not pray with those who were praying
because salah is the first thing that a
person will be judged for on the day of
judgment.
Let me ask you a question.
The people who are disbelievers, they
disbelieve, they do not just disbelieve
in Islam,
they disbelieve in whatever has reached
them of the religion of the prophets and
messengers.
They they do not worship Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. They do not follow a book.
They do not follow a religion. They just
exist however they feel that day or
however society tells them and whatever
is most popular.
Why is it so important to such an
individual to be considered a good
person?
If a person doesn't believe
in Allah, doesn't believe in the last
day, why is it so important to them that
they be a good person? What is good and
evil anyways without a creator? If there
is no creator, how can there exist good
and evil? These are just realities,
things that exist. It's not good or
evil. There is no morality without a
creator. Because the creator subhanahu
wa'ta'ala,
what he deems to be good is what is
morally good. and what he deems to be
bad is what is morally bad. But if a
person sees the world as just a natural
phenomenon,
just something that
grinded its way to this present moment,
just you know, wombs that are pushing
out babies and holes that are taking
taking in corpses. And that's all the
world is and that's all that existence
is.
Then how can there be such morality as
good and evil?
People know that there is a God. They
know that there is a creator. They
understand
deep within themselves because of the
fra that there is a day of judgment that
there is good and evil that they will be
asked why did you and why did you not
even if a person argues otherwise Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
the human being
is a witness
over himself and his faults and his
misdeeds and his wrongdoings. Even if he
gives himself in argument, excuse after
excuse, he knows deep down. He knows
because of the
it's deep in the heart, deep in the
soul. And this is why people when they
are on the brink of death, who do they
call out to? Allah. When they are in
looking death in the eye, who are they
calling to? Allah. And it's only one.
It's not many.
And it's not people or human beings or
angels. It is Allah.
The one that they gesture up to, the one
that is above,
the one.
And so people think that they can make
up their own excuses before Allah.
They don't follow any religion. They
don't look to seek the truth. They don't
look to seek if Allah has communicated
with them through prophets and
messengers.
But then they do things that they deem
to be good thinking that this will
intercede on their behalf on the day
of judgment that they're making for
themselves an argument.
Well, you know, I help people and I
worry about people and I give and I do
this and I give to charity and I do all
these things on my terms, but hopefully
in their heart of hearts, they believe
that this will intercede on their behalf
with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that they can say, well, you know, I
didn't do everything you asked, but look
at all this good stuff I did, right? I
was so kind. I was so good. I didn't
murder people. I didn't do this. I
didn't do that. Why? To give themselves
some kind of argument before Allah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala responds to
that argument here. He says that they
will say we were not of the people who
prayed and we did not feed the hungry,
the ms
and we used to
And we used to spend our time
and squander our time in that which
is false in falsehood
mulling it over. He says, "Subhanala,
and we also belied the day of reckoning,
the day of judgment. We belied it. We
disbelieved in it. We didn't really
believe it would come." Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala here says
he says
hence
meaning based on what is passed
[Silence]
So because of that
no intercession of any interceder
will be of consequence for them will be
of benefit to them.
Look at the wording of it.
foreign.
[Silence]
He says subhanahua
so no intercession
of any interceder will be of consequence
for them.
It will not be of consequence for them.
Not any good deed that they think they
did. Not any argument that they think
they constructed.
They didn't worship Allah on his terms.
They worshiped Allah on their terms. Do
not think for a moment that there is a
human being on this earth who has both
sanity and mind intact.
No matter what they claim of atheist
belief that in private they are not
building an argument for themselves
before Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in
their heart of hearts. No matter what
they say out loud and in public in their
private private life behind closed
doors, they are trying to build an
argument for themsel in front of Allah
just in case. And you you see this when
they rationalize
very famous atheists of our time and
even before,
right? Bertrren Russell and Dawkins
and Krauss and all of these different
contemporary and past atheists. They
will write an entire book
on
proving that God does not exist. Even
though this is an impossibility, it's a
logical fallacy in and of itself. How
can you prove
that he for certain does not exist?
However, beyond this, you'll find that
in the final chapters or in their final
words, what do they say? They leave room
for, "What if
God does exist?
What would I tell him when I meet him?"
Barton Russell had a part of this where
he talked about this. Dawkins has a part
of this in his books that he talks about
this. They've prepared an argument. What
if God does exist? What am I going to
tell him? So Bertram Russell says, I am
going to tell him why did you take such
pains to conceal yourself?
Right?
Notice the wording here. He's already
assumed that if a god does exist, he
will ask him and he's going to respond
and he's going to have a dialogue with
this god who described this god to him.
Was it his logic? No. It is the religion
of all the prophets and messengers. He
knows very well that he's going to be
asked, but he thinks that he's going to
argue his way out of it on a
technicality and that he's going to get
to have his cake and eat it at the same
time.
This is only in their imagination.
But when it comes time to truly meet
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, when one
stands before Allah, the judge of
judges, and even your skin
bears witness against you, how can you
argue in such a court when Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us of such
horrors
that a man's mouth will be sealed and
his skin and his eyes and his ears and
his limbs will start to testify against
him. What possible argument can a person
make before Allah if this is the case?
There is no argument for the rejection
of the prophets and messengers of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. No matter what good
a person thinks he is doing outside of
that, all
relationship with Allah is founded and
based upon belief in his prophets and
messengers. And so these individuals,
Allah tells us that no intercession of
any interceder
shall be of any consequence for them on
the day of judgment.
Subhanahu wa'tala.
[Arabic recitation]